There was an idea.
To bring together a group of remarkable people.
In time, you will know what it's like to lose.
To feel so desperately that you're right.
We just gotta load Tony old Hulkbuster armor, prototype for Cap's new shield.
Yet to fail all the same .
Run from it.
Destiny still arrives.
Suddenly those offhanded remarks during Spider-man Homecoming make a lot more sense now. Now we know where that
Hulkbuster came from. So this is gonna be video all about Hulk and the
Hulkbuster during the Infinity War trailer and during the movie because they're using him for some Silver Surfer stuff from the Thanos Infinity Gauntlet storyline
and they're having some fun with the character at the expense of Avengers: Age of Ultron.
Just a funny idea on the twist of what the Hulkbuster
represents in the fight that they had during Age of Ultron. So if you are finding me for the first time
we're doing Marvel every week. Be sure to subscribe, to get everything! There's even giveaway stuff happening at the end of the video too.
But starting with the funny stuff first. So a lot of people saw this trailer in the way that the Hulkbuster
lands, it lands the way that the Hulk lands when he jumps really far.
It doesn't land the way that Tony Stark lands when he's wearing the Hulkbuster, so people are like:
'Oh, there's got to be somebody else inside there!'
Maybe it's the Hulk himself because there's a corresponding shot of a piece of the Hulkbuster armor
standing next to Banner while Black Widow is just watching him like: "Oh my God!
I haven't seen this guy since Avengers: Age of Ultron. Where the hell
did you go big guy?" and she has that smile on her face.
Just like 'Wow, this is an awkward moment'. So the idea is that she's standing out in this field in Wakanda here
and it's like: "Oh, here comes Stark in the Hulkbuster or whatever" and out climbs Banner, and it's a funny
'HAHA' moment. But rewind to the beginning of the movie.
Why would the Hulk be
inside the Hulkbuster? Other than for it to be a very funny moment.
There's got to be an actual reason for it. The reason why is probably just for pure
transportation reasons. Like they probably want to get the Hulkbuster down there because they want to have the Hulkbuster fight Black Dwarf when
he lands with the other outriders, at this big invasion here. The armor itself
we know is in upstate New York at the Avengers facility
per Spider Man homecoming, when Happy was loading all the gear off the Avengers Tower.
This is all happening after the events of the Spider-Man Homecoming, so whoever they've sold the tower to, they finished that up.
There's no more Avenger stuff inside there. So there's this scene of Hulk crashing through the Sanctum. Dr.
Strange and Wong looking down like: "What the hell is Bruce Banner doing here?".
They always seem to know who weird people are when they show up, like: 'Your brother Loki is here! What is he doing here?
He caused a lot of problems the last time he was around.' So he shows up and Hulk is probably
serving the role of the Silver Surfer
during Thanos quest. A lot of you guessed that during the trailer. Like are they gonna give him the Silver Surfer
storyline where he warns Dr. Strange about Thanos? So in that storyline
what happens is, is Silver Surfer is just going across the universe.
He's The Herald of Galactus, so he's out on his normal business. He comes across Thanos
who's in the process of battling other powerful cosmic beings to get the Infinity Gems. Thanos
punts him across the universe and he
crash-lands in Dr. Strange's Sanctum and gives him this great warning that 'Death is coming for everyone!'
So he becomes the first member of the Avengers to find out what's going on
and he warns everyone else. So careful for spoilers for the end of Thor: Ragnarok,
if you haven't seen that movie yet. At the end of that movie,
it looks like Thanos's ship shows up.
So it sounds like when shit goes down on the ship here, Loki sends everyone in opposite directions
using the Tesseract. So that's how Hulk gets back into Earth's atmosphere.
But because this is like a two-and-a-half-hour movie, Iron Man probably instantly detects Hulk in Earth's atmosphere,
comes to find him and then meets Doctor Strange.
They have sort of that funny moment: the comedy of just seeing the Hulk lying there and all that debris in wondering how he got
there, wondering how he was able to break through all the enchantments protecting the Sanctum Sanctorum,
because as cool as it is seeing all these characters on screen for the first time: you have to
remember that the Sanctum is one of the most protected places on the Earth and Hulk literally just crashes right through the barrier.
It'd be like him tearing through enchantments like tissue paper.
And then a lot of you also
detected that Tony whips out the cell phone the Captain America gave him at the end of Civil War, like he's instantly
calling Cap: 'Holy shit! Get the band back together.' Are you Tony
Stank?
Tony. I wish we agreed on the Accords. I really do.
I know you're doing what you believe in, and that's all any of us can do. That's all any of us should. If you need us.
If you need me.
I'll be there. So you see them all standing here,
he's still Banner in the street while they're looking up at the sky.
This is probably when Thanos's ship first comes down and then they need to get to Wakanda for some reason. So at some point later
in the film they need to take all their resources down there, for whatever this big final battle is. But what might end up happening
is, is like you see Banner standing here? He hasn't turned into the Hulk again?
He might be afraid to turn back into the Hulk
but they still need to get him down to Wakanda, so Tony is probably like: 'I have an idea!'
and then you just cut to a scene of him inside the Hulk Buster flying to
Wakanda. So when it lands here for the first time he still climbs out and he's Banner.
But obviously we've seen the trailer scene of them, all running into battle behind Captain America and Black Panther here. He's gone
fully Hulk. We see the Hulk Buster way down here in the field but Black Widow's running behind them here.
So either Friday is auto-piloting the Hulkbuster during this big fight for Black Widow climbs into it.
But you can kind of see how they're doing a lot of comic book Thanos quest stuff with the characters that they have on screen.
Like they don't have a Silver Surfer. Even if the Fox deal goes through they've already shot the movie.
They're not gonna add Silver Surfer in the next couple of weeks.
But I know a lot of you have been asking about that.
Renewed box
Disney talks, like they say that they're back in the meeting room now trying to hash out a deal: for them to either buy
most of Fox's assets or find a sharing arrangement, so if that were to happen right away
I think the first thing Marvel would go for would be the Fantastic Four
characters because Reed Richards would work really well with the characters they already have on screen.
He's one of the Illuminati, and they could use him in a limited way the way that they used Dr.
Strange. So like Doctor Strange had a solo movie, but for the most part he just popped up in other people's films.
Just because the character himself isn't quite as popular as some of the other A-list Avengers.
But after that if they have the Marvel Cosmic Universe that James Gunn's been hyping up.
I did a video about that a little while ago.
They could use Galactus as the big bad of the next phase of Marvel cosmic films.
They could do Ultimates, like you can't really do Ultimates without Galactus.
And it would just be really awesome to see comic book
versions of a lot of those Fox characters. Now X-Men is kind of a sipper thing. We could talk about X-Men vs.
Avengers
but the X-Men timeline is so messy that if they do wind up making the deal, sharing characters and using X-Men characters,
I think it'll be on a limited basis. Like they would go for Wolverine
and they would try to do a more comic bookie version of that character eventually.
But let me know in the comments! They get access to the Fox characters,
which ones do you want them to grab first for the initial  Phase 4 films?
I think a lot of people are just waiting for Fantastic Four, like they've been drug through the mud so much people just want to
see a good version of some of those characters or at least one of them being Reed Richards.
But there's plenty more Avengers on the way. There obviously be more Black Panther dropping really soon.
So just leave all your bonus video requests in the comments! :)
There is a new round of that Imax ticket giveaway. All you have to do to enter is just be a subscriber and leave an Avengers
related comment on the video.
Congratulations to the winner from my last video: Brandon Navarro.
Please private message me so I can get your contact details.
To answer your question: Clark Gregg in real life actually said that Coulson
would not be going back into the movies. In that way if he does, we might get a cameo during
Captain Marvel set in the past.
But we can talk about that if we learn more about Captain Marvel. So click here to learn all about the Infinity Gems and click
here to learn all about Snokes's backstory and his powers in the Last Jedi. Thank you so much for watching! Everybody stay awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight.